what is the arrow of time it's the
simple fact that the past is different
from the future right if you were an
astronaut in your spacesuit far up in
orbit far away from everything else
there would be no arrow of space all the
directions you could point in would be
equally good you wouldn't even notice
you wouldn't be able to say I was facing
up or facing down but not obviously
that's not true for time everyone agrees
on which direction of time is yesterday
in which direction is tomorrow for
example we can remember things that
happened yesterday none of us can
remember things that happen tomorrow
even though things will happen so
there's a million ways in which one
direction of time moving toward the past
looks different to us than the other
direction moving to the future and that
directedness from past to future is the
arrow of time
this is a great example of a problem
that only exists because you learn a
little bit you didn't think that it was
a problem you know you don't see
Aristotle or Descartes worrying about
the arrow of time right well what
happens is we developed some notion of
the fundamental laws of physics starting
with Galileo and Newton and working up
through Maxwell and Einstein and others
there's a feature of Newton's laws for
example which is that they don't have an
arrow of time they treat directionality
toward the future and directional a
toward the past exactly the same one way
of saying it is if you if you make a
movie of an egg breaking and being
scrambled and you play it backwards it's
obvious that you're playing it backwards
right you notice it that's the arrow of
time you can notice when someone
reverses it but when you make a movie of
a pendulum swinging back and forth very
simple system or you made a movie of the
earth going around the Sun another very
simple system if you played those
backward you wouldn't be able to tell
that they were reversed and that's
because we need a small number of pieces
fundamental physics without dissipation
and friction and noise and all that
stuff
there isn't any arrow of time so the the
puzzle that we need to explain is how to
reconcile the absence of an arrow at the
microscopic fundamental level with the
obvious presence of the arrow in our
everyday lives but with that pendulum in
the earth you say there wasn't an arrow
there was an arrow just it just wasn't
obvious it was just harder to say
because of the visual properties of the
system no no if you if you look at the
equations look at the equations for the
earth going around the Sun they're
reversible right if you take the earth
put it in the same position but reverse
its velocity it will exactly retrace the
path that it took so the fundamental
laws of physics have this property that
for every way that you can evolve
forward in time there is an exactly
corresponding way that you can both
evolve backward in time the macroscopic
world is irreversible you can take the
AG and you can scramble it but you can't
unscramble the egg very easily or to put
it this way if you come across like a
cool glass of water it might have been
the 10 minutes ago it was a cool glass
water or it might have been a warm glass
of water with an ice cube in it you
can't tell the difference from the
present state of the system whereas
Newton's laws say that if you know the
present state of the system you can
always uniquely tell us where it came
from but with your glass of ice water or
your scrambled egg why is it not the
case that it is reversible just our
feeble Minds couldn't possibly come up
with the complex equations well it is at
some level so if when you looked at the
glass of water instead of seeing water
you saw with your eyeballs the position
and velocity of every water molecule and
your brain was good enough to do the
calculation then you could reverse it
and that is the secret to reconciling
the microscopic reversibility to the
macroscopic irreversibility namely that
in the macroscopic world we don't see
everything we only see some
coarse-grained features of reality when
we have the air in this room we don't
see the position and velocity of every
air molecule and it turns out that in
that coarse-grained description of
reality the past is very very different
from the future and the way that we
characterized this is by entropy of
course entropy is the way the physicists
talk about the disorderliness the
messiness the chaoticness of the
macroscopic universe and there's a law
of thermodynamics the second law of
thermodynamics very famous says that
entropy increases toward the future
that's easy to understand actually
getting Messier is a very natural thing
the hard thing to understand is that
entropy was lower in the past that's the
same statement as entropy increasing
toward the future but there's no easy
dynamical principle of physics that
would explain why the entropy was ever
low in particular in the real world it
was low 13.7 billion years ago near the
Big Bang our our observable universe
started in a state of exquisite order
and then ever since it's been expanding
and cooling and disorderliness has come
into being so really it becomes a
cosmology question we understand the
equations behind the arrow of time what
we don't understand is why was ever put
into the universe at the Big Bang
does time flow just in wonder
like a river then or are you saying it
is going both ways
well time flowing has always been a
somewhat dicey kind of simile or
metaphor because flowing means changing
with time and time doesn't change with
time we we speak about time we don't use
very precise language very often but I
think you know an accurate way of saying
the same question is does time truly
have a directionality or at the
fundamental level or both directions of
time on an equal footing I would say
that at the fundamental level both
directions of time are equal that when
we observe the arrow of time in our real
world it's just like the arrow of space
here on earth remember we did the
analogy with the astronaut we had to go
up into orbit far away from the earth
here on the surface there's a difference
between up and down I should say down
and up right why is there that
difference well because we are in the
vicinity of a very influential object
the earth that's what gives space its
arrow locally what I'm saying is that
the reason why there's an arrow of time
is precisely analogous there's an arrow
of time in our environment because we
are in the vicinity of a very
influential event the Big Bang there's
two kinds of questions that arise here
one is a good kind of question one is it
not so good kind of question but not so
good kind of question is there are many
many people out there who just deny the
fact that the origin of the arrow of
time is the fact that our early universe
had a low entropy there were debates
that went on it from the 19th century
from the you know 1870s with Boltzmann
and Maxwell and Gibbs and Lowe Schmidt
and Zermelo and others trying to figure
out how to reconcile microscopic
reversibility with macroscopic
irreversibility and they sort of solved
the problem halfway they said if you
have a low entropy condition long ago
then entropy increases and everything
follows what they didn't do is explain
to us why we had a low entropy boundary
condition very long ago modern cosmology
says you know we can blame it on the Big
Bang it doesn't solve the problem right
it just puts it off to the Big Bang but
we don't mention the Big Bang when we
teach people thermodynamics or
statistical
mechanics because that's all about
predicting the future it's not about
retro dick ting the past so many people
including people who know a lot of
physics don't get that you need to put a
boundary condition at the Big Bang to
understand the arrow of time those
people are just incorrect the other
thing of course is well if you do want
to explain why the early universe had a
low entropy what's the right explanation
does inflationary cosmology already
explain it does Stephen Hawking's wave
function of the universe already explain
it you need a multiverse to explain it
she just accept it as a brute fact and
not look for explanations these are very
good questions these are all viable
alternatives on the table it's part and
parcel of what we discuss in modern
cosmology you live on earth as a human
you know you had to be here at 3 o'clock
you've got to be on your plane tomorrow
time rules your life as a human when you
think about time as much as you do on
this higher plane does it affect your
everyday life do you distill all these
times that somehow seem irrelevant or
other two very separate parts of your
personality well I think that the way
that we human beings very correctly
perceive the world is a multi-leveled
way and especially if you're a working
physicist you better think this way and
you know you don't need to use the
standard model of particle physics to
scramble your egg that would make life
very very difficult indeed so we have
different kinds of vocabularies we have
this fundamental vocabulary of particle
physics and quantum mechanics and
relativity and then this higher level
vocabulary of thermodynamics and fluids
and and objects and solids and an even
higher level vocabulary human beings and
their wants and desires and aspirations
and thoughts and rational reasons and so
forth so they all fit together there are
connections between the different levels
and it's all one consistent story I
believe we haven't figured out all the
details of that consistent story but I
get just as anxious when I'm running
late as anyone who doesn't know anything
whatsoever about the arrow of time the
Higgs boson is a tiny little vibration
in a field called the Higgs field just